94 metros de largo 14 metros de ancho y
un objetivo la lucha contra el
narcotráfico el barco francés germinal
llegó a la ciudad de cartagena en el mar
caribe no se pactó navajas strategic e
texto no propongo esta alianza
estratégica es muy importante para
nosotros porque nos permite conocer
mejor los flujos marítimos de
estupefacientes que parten de colombia
el coliseo también de colombia es el
primer productor de cocaína en el mundo
es una nación que lucha activamente
contra el narcotráfico lo del
narcotráfico una parada más del buque
que solo en 2021 decomisó 5 toneladas de
cocaína e interpeló a 13
narcotraficantes la alianza se enmarca
en la campaña naval orión una operación
multilateral liderada por colombia que
pretende acabar con el tráfico de
estupefacientes en la región del caribe
y que reconoce el narcotráfico como un
tema transnacional la cooperación entre
francia y colombia es parte de un de
otra fuerza multinacional en la que
están metidos un montón de actores y
francia en colombia son apenas uno de
uno apenas dos de los 41 países que
están vinculados la cooperación entre
ambos países no es algo nuevo los
franceses persiguen varios objetivos
sobre todo con su presencia del caribe y
en sus territorios de ultramar y es muy
interesante que francia se vinculen más
con colombia en todo lo que sea
seguridad porque a veces políticamente
ha habido ciertas diferencias el
germinal llega a colombia en medio de
varios pendientes en la lucha contra el
narcotráfico solo en 2021 la producción
potencial de cocaína aumentó en un 8%
según la onu y el paro armado llevado a
cabo por el clan del golfo que afectó a
casi un tercio del país expone el
poderío que siguen teniendo los grupos
narcotraficantes en el país